SPEAKER: Have you
ever considered
how your choice of database
could ease development and help
accelerate your time to market?
Google Cloud Spanner,
the horizontally-scalable
relational database,
provides all the familiarity
of relational databases such
as transactions across rows,
enforce data types, schema,
and complex queries,
meaning no time lost learning
new languages or paradigms.
And, unlike traditional
relational databases,
Cloud Spanner grows with
the needs of your app
so you can have confidence
in the knowledge
that you'll never have
to re-platform for scale.
Cloud Spanner not only allows
you to deploy your application
faster, it also delivers
a better user experience
by improving data consistency,
eliminating inconsistent reads,
and helping to reduce
time-consuming bugs.
Google Cloud Spanner-- fast
track your application's path
to success.